who is isaiah 42 talking about well
there's three opinions
amongst the rabbis it's either talking
about the jewish people always talking
about
king cyrus the great always talking
about the prophet isaiah himself
okay where's kedar keda is let's keep
house in
in the arabian peninsula first of all we
need to look at this
chapter in context and the way to look
at it in context is by looking at
the previous chapter is this a
coincidence the very things that he's
talking about
happened in that region in the arabian
peninsula
talking about the defeat of idol
worshipers if i want any non-muslim here
are you a muslim
you're not okay can i ask you a question
if i
told you that in the arabian peninsula
there was a prophet who defeated the
idols
who would come to your mind
mohammed did you hear that and then god
says i have raised up one from the north
who is this one from the north here is
cyrus the great muhammad is muhammad is
not from the north now this is from the
south
because you're either gonna deny the
occurrence which denies your very book
or you're going to accept it and give me
another narrative
in history that fought and defeated the
idol worshipers
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
so i'm going to go to isaiah 42 yes the
famous isaiah 42.
who is isaiah 42 talking about well
there's three opinions
amongst amongst amongst the rabbis it's
either talking about the jewish people
and i'm going to prove as to how they
get that always talking about king cyrus
the great
um and i'll prove how they get that
always talking about the prophet isaiah
himself
um and there's a proof of that too okay
so for example let me read it for the
people yeah
here is my servant whom i whom i upload
uphold my chosen one in whom i delight i
will put my spirit on him
and he will bring justice to the nations
he will and he's talking about nations
by the way
he will not shout or cry out or raise
his voice in the streets
or bruised reed he will not break
and the smoldering wick he will not
snuff out in faithfulness he will bring
forth justice
he will not falter or be discouraged
till he is established justice on earth
it is it it's in his teachings the
islands were put there
put their hope that is what god the lord
says
the creator of the heavens who stretched
them out and spread out the earth
with all that springs from it and who
gives breath so its people
until and life to those who walk on it i
the lord have called you in
righteousness
i will take hold of your hand i will
keep you and will make you
will make you to be a covenant so
there's a new covenant yeah
for the people and the light for the
gentiles so specifically
for the gentiles yeah like for the
gentiles says that life of the nations
but
it's mine are different i don't know
this is gentiles i don't know maybe
nations okay so for our nation then yeah
okay
that's good because we believe the
prophet came for all nations not
specifically for the gentiles
to open eyes so it came to the children
of israel and the whole gentiles
to open the eyes that are blind to free
the captives from prison and to release
from the dungeon those who sit in
darkness
i am the lord that is my name i will not
yield my glory to another
or my praise to idols so we're speaking
specifically
about idols yeah so in this region there
must have been idols
see the former things have taken place
and new things i declare
before they spring into being i announce
them to you
sing to the lord a new song so there's a
new song well let me say new song we're
not talking about a song that you sing
yeah
his praise from the ends of the earth
you who go down to the sea and all that
is in
it in it in it you islands and all
and all who live in them let the
wilderness and its towns raise their
voices let the settlements where kedar
kedar kedar lives rejoice
let the people of selah these are very
important uh geographically where are
these places sellers sing for joy
let them shout from mountaintops you
know we have narrations from the prophet
peace be upon him
let them give glory to the lord and
proclaim his praise in the islands the
lord will march out like a champion
like a warrior he will stir up his zeal
with a shout he will raise the battle of
christ and trump over
triumph over his enemies for a long time
i have kept silent i have been quiet and
held myself back
but now like a woman in childbirth i cry
out grasp and pant
i will lay waste the mountains and the
hills and dry up all their vegetations
and
i will turn rivers into islands and dry
up the pools
i will leave the blind by the ways they
have not known along unfamiliar pipes i
will guide them
i will turn the darkness into light
before them and make the rough
places smooth these are the things i
will do i will
i will not forsake them but those who
trust in idols who say images you are
gods you are gods will be turned back in
utter shame so the idol worshipers
will be destroyed so can you explain to
us the three options that you said
they are why are you disregarding that
it's in a specific region
yeah in the arabian peninsula where why
can't it not be prophet muhammad but
it's the other thing that you're seeing
because specifically
he's talking about mount sailor so first
of all first of all
we need to look at this chapter in
context and the way to look at it in
context is by looking at
the previous chapter so we'll if you
turn
to chapter 41
we'll start from verse 8. okay
forty one verse eight and we'll start
from there and this will make a lot more
sense
okay but thou yes
israel aren't my servant so who's the
servant of god
israel whom i have chosen
the seed of abraham my friend
thou whom i have taken from the ends of
the earth and called thee from its
farthest corners and said to thee thou
art my servant
i have chosen thee and not cast thee
away
right the servant of god is israel is
the people of israel
fear not for i am with thee be not
dismayed for i am thy god
i will strengthen thee indeed i will
help thee moreover
i will uphold thee with the right hand
of my righteousness
behold all they that were incensed
against thee
shall be ashamed and confounded
they shall be as nothing and they have
and they that strive with thee
their with thee shall perish thou shalt
seek them
and shalt not find them those that
contend with thee
they that war against thee shall be as
nothing and as a thing of naught
for i the lord thy god will hold thy
right hand
saying to thee fear not i will help thee
fear not thou warn ya o men of israel
i will help thee says the lord and thy
redeemer the holy one of your saw hill
behold i will make of thee a new sharp
threshing instrument having teeth
thou shalt thresh the mountains and beat
them small and shalt make the hills as
chaff
thou shalt found them and the wind shall
carry them away and the storm wind shall
scatter them
and thou shalt rejoice in the lord and
shalt glory in the holy one of israel
the poor and needy seek water and there
is none
and their tongue is parched for thirst i
the lord will answer them
either got to be so able not to forsake
them i will open rivers on high places
and mountains in the midst of the
valleys
i will make the wilderness a pool of
water and the dry land
springs of water i will plant in the
wilderness the cedar the shattar tree
and the myrtle and the oil tree
i will set in the aovo cypress maple and
box tree together
and they that they may see and know and
consider and understand together
that the hand of the lord has done this
and the holy one of israel has created
it
produce your cause says the lord bring
forth your strong reasons
says the king of your arkhov let them
bring forth and tell us what shall
happen
let them relate the former things what
they were that you may consider them and
know the latter end of them or the chaos
things to come
so at this point the question is so god
has stopped talking in the third person
at this point
god is now talking in the second person
so who is he talking to
so now in the next verse we find out who
he's talking to he says declare the
things that are to come here after
that we may know that you are gods so
clearly he's talking to the
idols he's now referring to the idols
indeed do good or do evil that we may be
dismayed
and behold it together behold you are of
nothing and your work of naught an
abomination is he that chooses you
it's an abomination is he that chooses
idols right
so idols if you're able to if you're
able to prove us
that you're that you're true go ahead
try it right but of course you can't
you're
you are of naught an abomination is he
that chooses you
and then god says i have raised up one
from the north
who is this one from the north here's
cyrus the great
the one from the north mohammed is
mohammed is not from the north now this
is from the south
this is just before i've raised that one
from the north and he has come
right so so far what we've seen is that
we have this servant of god
who is israel okay that's what we've
seen so far in 41
8 and also 41 9 the hallways through
he's talking about the servant
and it's israel then he turned his
attention to the idols and started um
saying um
try to try to say that you're that
you're right or whatever
you won't be able to right and anyone
who follows you
is an abomination and now he says i have
raised up one from the north and he has
come
from the uh and he has come from the
rising of the sun
and he shall call upon my name and he
shall come upon princes as upon mortar
and as potter treads clay who has
declared from the beginning that we may
know and before time that we may say he
is right
there is none that told none the
declared not even um
not one even that heard your words
okay so over here is talking about this
person from the north now we say the
person of the north
is simus the great right okay let's say
that
um will i give behold behold them until
you shall i am a messenger of good
tidings
for i behold and there is no man among
them and there is no counsellor that
when i ask of them
could answer a word behold they are all
vanity he's talking about the idols
they are all vanity their works are
nothing their molten idols are wins and
confusion
behold my servant so now he goes back to
the servant so the question at this
point is
we were just talking two paragraphs ago
about god's servant and he said
specifically god so it was israel
why should we think that now that
servant has suddenly changed to a
different person
now that is that is the that is
according to explanation that says that
this is israel
there is another possibility that says
well
we have interrupted and said talked
about this person from the north cyrus
okay so maybe the servant is actually
cyrus okay so that's the explanation
that says it's cyrus
i don't find that particularly
convincing it seems that
there's no reason to change between the
servants but uh
but who am i to judge these are great
people saying these things
and there's a third explanation which is
isaiah and they prove it from
various things in the grammar in isaiah
49
and compare it to the words here and say
it's the same words and therefore
it's really the same person i'm not
entirely clear on that explanation
i am going to say this very it looks
very clear that is
this is clearly israel every time it's
the servant it's always israel
there's no reason to say this one is any
different um
yeah that's my position well josh
i don't know it just seemed like you
just read isaiah 41
with all due respect you brought your
little twist to it you pointed it up to
north to
what was his name cyrus the great king
of pleasure
what well north okay what i really want
to ask is
when did the children of israel or the
chosen prophet israel ever went to
kedar yeah kedar is not any region but
i've said they're going to
no no it says read in isaiah 42. can you
tell me can you tell me which prophet
or which which okay okay firstly he
brings a new song
yes a new law no no
no one second he's bringing a new law in
kedar
in mount
yes we believe the prophet muhammed
because the thing is in that region of
kedar
in mount sila can i just finish please
in the region of kedar yeah
yeah okay in mount sela
yeah can you tell me put prophet
muhammed to his side
peace be upon him can you give me any
historical event
that a person because we believe the
prophet muhammad came destroy the idol
worshippers
can you tell me any other person but
prophet muhammad peace be upon him to
aside
that these occurrences happened because
you're either going to deny the
occurrence
which denies your very book or you're
going to
accept it and give me another narrative
in history
that fought and defeated the idol
worshipers and they went back running
their tails between their legs in an
area uh kedar
in specific mountain mount selah can you
tell me
any other instance in history from the
children israel
to your what's his name again up north
cyrus cyrus whoever is here can you tell
me any other instances in history
apart from the very specific instance
where we're looking our
traditions that prophet muhammed came
and destroyed the idol worshippers
whether or not new with the new law i
just want to know who else could it be
well we believe that this has not yet
happened we believe this is something
that's coming in the future in the end
of days
the times of the messiah um what's very
important to
to understand um here is
that when let's analyze the song let's
analyze the song
okay god says sing well let's sing to
the lord a new song
okay sings the lord to the new song okay
this is in the imperative
which means a second person he's talking
to someone but he's not talking to
someone
because the word is shiru okay the word
sing to the lord of
new song the first word to sing in
hebrew is the word
now shiru is imperative it's second
person
but it's not just any second person it's
not second person singular it's second
person plural
this means he's talking to a group of
people he's talking to lots of people
so who is he talking to the companion
well hold on hold on
let's see let's see what the verses come
out so she will hashem
sing okay to lots of people okay
sing to the lord a new song
okay his um his his praise from the end
of the earth so saying to the lord
whose song his plays from the end of the
earth okay it's there's a parallelism
in this verse okay a new song and his uh
and his praise right you're singing a
new song you're singing the praise
right
so who's he talking to now we see people
that he's talking to
who is he talking to he's talking to you
what does that mean you that go down to
the sea all that there is
is there in the isles and all the
inhabitants so who is god telling to
sing this song
okay at this point all we see is the
people of the islands
okay people who go down to the sea all
right the island dwellers these kind of
people
next yes
let the wilderness and the cities lift
up their voice the villagers
the villagers the villagers that play
though inhabit in
inhabits okay so now it's not only the
sea inhabitants
okay who god's telling to sing the song
it's not only the island's dwellers
it's also now people of the wilderness
people of very dry places like credo
your own new yoshi
is not the name of a place nowhere else
in the tanakh
comes up over 200 times in the tanakh
nowhere else does it refer to a place
it always means rock or bedrock over
here joshua
there might be a mountain called seller
but seller
but seller but seller is all always
refers to a rock i can refer you to
numbers where it says
where it says that moshe here to set up
what moshe went to the mountain in
arabia and hits the mountain center no
he hit him
we know it's like a mountain
always means rock the inhabitant
from the top of the mountains they shall
they shall um
what's the word yes they shall they they
shall give glory
um no they shall
they shall shout so so what's going on
here
god okay this song is to be sung
for from all different parts of the
world right
like from the ends of the world it's
going to be sung it's going to be sung
from it's going to be sung by the
islanders and those who live on the sea
in the deserts in the deserts and the
hot places like playdoh
right now it doesn't say anything about
law it's a song
um okay it's it's not about song the
praise of god
okay when you sing to god you're
praising to god that's not
about law law
how are you going to learn what to sing
or praise god
if you're not being told what if they
pray
if you don't allow us to you created the
world
it's very easy to praise god last time
when we spoke that's the reason why you
said the message of the prophet is true
because he went to different nations and
told them to worship god alone
and that is the reason why they are
praising the praise of their lord
now i want to ask you this question
there's a person
from from can you tell me tell me okay
kate
where's kedar kedah there is this house
in the arabian peninsula okay
so you're telling me it's a coincidence
that
for some reason the bible specifically
mentions kedar it mentions specifically
selah for some reason he could have
mentioned anywhere else it couldn't say
anything else about the mount mount
cellar
and then there's going to be a the the
other worshipers are going to be
destroyed
a new song a new law and i asked you a
specific question
i said give me any other example because
what it seems like is that you're trying
to
you know um i'm sorry to me it just
seems that you're just trying your best
to push it aside i'll ask again can you
give me
any other example in history prophet
muhammed aside because prophet muhammed
came in that specific region he beat the
idol worshippers
and he he praises the lord now
no no no no no no where is your evidence
that it hasn't happened yet
number one where is evidence that it's
for the future number two
can you give me any evidence that
besides prophet muhammed a
occurrence like this has happened if you
if you say it's in the future whatever
it is in the future
what do you mean what's my evidence in
the future well she evidenced that this
is in the future that he hasn't happened
that has my evidence that it hasn't
happened is that
it is that you don't have is that you
don't have all the
all these people from the from the
islands we do islam
all over the world because look i can
say look am i
josh i can say that matches nearly
exactly the prophet muhammad it's very
who for the idol worships prophet
muhammed who came praising the song with
his companions ten thousand of them
near mount sila and on a mountain in
kedar prophet muhammad
who is the one who spread the law around
the regions that people like me have
come to islam and we praise the
sanctity of god and you're the same
person last week who said we believe in
i believe you said i believe in the
message of the prophet because he spread
and destroyed i do worship him i do
worshipping
and enabled these nations to worship god
alone
you said it with your own mouth so josh
josh no okay josh you tell me why is
this ingenuous because i don't want to
tell you okay please tell me and please
answer my questions
why in the future if not in the future
which other occurrence happened that put
prophet muhammed to aside
it's in the future because this is in
the first of all
first of all um if this is all connected
to the servant
okay let's start there this is all
connected to this servant
and we've established from the previous
chapter the servant of god is israel
and it's not talking about muhammad any
instance that israel came to cado
it doesn't say that people are coming to
kedar okay
it says that it says that israel are
going to do certain things
okay the people of israel are going to
do certain things and i should probably
mention
very important when we talk about the
servant of god
being israel we're talking about those
people of israel who actually serve god
obviously it's not wicked jews
that would not make any sense at all
right it wouldn't
it wouldn't it wouldn't be people who
are not religious it's talking about
people
who serve god okay the servants of god
okay when we say the servant of god is
israel that is obviously
that is obviously the the pious ones the
righteous ones
right yeah of course
so here in 42 directly following isaiah
41 where the servant was israel here the
sermon is also israel now once we say
that the seventh
because it directly follows it can you
give me an instance that this appearance
happened
so what i'm saying what my argument
actually is is that once you
have established the servant has to be
israel based on the previous chapter
therefore if you see these things
haven't happened and you believe that
these things
are supposed to happen at some point
that means that they will happen in the
future
if israel has not caused these things to
happen
then they then they haven't happened no
no you're you're stipulating it in there
you're saying no
it's the only option is israel yes if it
hasn't happened
that's exactly what i'm saying no no no
that you're you're you're you're adding
that in there now i'm not saying
where's your evidence that this is going
to occur in the future
you haven't given it my evidence is
going to happen in the future
in the future show me any text that says
this better occurrence in isaiah 42
is a prophecy in the future when is that
going to happen number two but it's
definitely
probably in the past is it it's all
written in the future tense number two
the prophet
with a new song that's going to be
praised around the world you're ignoring
the island's people you know we cannot
my argument now is what i'm saying look
what i'm saying what i'm saying is
you're telling me you're telling me that
that because muhammad
it seems what you're saying um it seems
like what you're saying is that because
muhammad is from the arabian peninsula
okay so it can only be muhammad being
talked about when he talks about
when he talks about that that seems to
be what you're saying
but by that logic but by that logic when
it says in the previous verse
that people singing the song are the are
those who go down to the sea and those
who live on the islands
that that means that well did muhammad
never go to the islands no no no no no
the message that the song that's been
spread the new song that they're
praising god as
islam grew you have people all over the
world
why are you making the specificity the
song is being praised until this day
from that moment
all around the world there's people who
live in the islands they're going to
live in the desert
so this still confirms that i'm asking
again
can you show me any other instance in
that region
the occurrence that happened with
prophet muhammed and i do worshippers
can you give me another figure north
south east
west anywhere that this very coincidence
is a coincidence that the question i
need to ask is this a coincidence
the very things that he's talking about
happened in
that region in the arabian peninsula and
talking about the defeat of idol
worshipers the only person if you went
to anybody
if i went to any non-muslim are you a
muslim you're not
you're a christian yeah if i was to can
i ask you a question it's just jewish
can i ask you a question can i ask you a
question
if i told you that in the arabian
peninsula there was a prophet who
defeated the idols
who would come to your mind
mohammed did you hear that she's a
christian she's not muslim
she said i said to her that if i was to
tell you
that did i pay you to come here no we
don't know each other
sorry yeah just to make it clear i
didn't i didn't i didn't pay you to come
here i said to you if i was to tell you
an arabian prophet or a person
defeated the idol worshipers he would
come to your mind i didn't pay her she
said muhammad
because that is the only instance now
what i'm asking josh is the following
please can you give me another example
put prophet muhammed to a side
under any other example in that region
that this very specific instance
happened
as i said as i said before
but you haven't actually answered the
point that i said
i said before that your only conjecture
that this is an arabian prophet being
spoken about here
is the fact it mentions kedar and and
sela which you believe
is a specific mountain in arabia that's
your conjecture
but that would imply that would imply
that when it says the islands it's it's
an islander person
right if okay if you can tell me it's an
arabian because it has a place in arabia
then i can tell you it's an island
though because it says islands
that's a bad argument it's very
disingenuous
there's still no reason to say that the
servant is not
israel there's still no reason to say
that
that that that israel has caused these
things to happen
and there's no reason to say it's an
arabian person being talked about
you know what's very interesting what's
very interesting in isaiah 42
as we carry on god is once again
cursing and rebuking the children of
israel and this idea 42. i didn't read
this bit
yeah it says hear you hear you deaf
look you blind and see who is blunt but
my
servant and death like the messenger i
sent
who is like the one who is the one in
covenant with me
blind like the servant of the lord you
may see see many things but you pay no
attention
here god is not only talking about a new
song that's going to be praised it's
like okay
okay that was the translation i didn't
do it myself if you read if you read it
it says hero definitely look i blind
that you may see
so that was fine who is blind but my
servant or death as my messenger that i
sent who's disturbance who is
hold on who is blind as as he that is
perfect
and blind as the lord's servants this is
not this is not as you're saying
like a a big rebuke okay it's god
rebuking the servants the
church of israel this is saying my
sermon i those who serve me
okay are are blind those the servants
huh the seven is israel okay so let me
get this right isaiah 42 is talking
about instance of a new song that's
going to be sent
okay one second isaiah 42 god almighty
is talking about
the new song that's going to be praised
i do worship they're going to be
destroyed in a specific region of kedar
specific mountain mount cellar a
specific region mount selah
and then he rebukes the children of
israel let me get this right
if i was to come and say there's going
to be a new i'm
a coach there's going to be a new
fighter and this fight is going to
destroy
mike tyson and this fight is going to do
and it's going to be in
america texas yeah and then i start
rebuking the other guy
and by the way i don't know let's say
this person he
is deaf and dumb or blind i'm just not
that he said exactly those words
that you know what that says to me that
says to me that
god is once again angry with the
children of israel because they break
the covenant over and over again
god has sent someone in kedar and that's
the reason why george i'll ask you again
amy please tell me another incidence and
i'm not being disingenuous if it comes
i'm sorry i'm not trying to become like
that i'm genuinely trying to find out
can you give me any other instance
occurrence of a character of a figure in
that specific region
that has done those very things put
prophet muhammed to a side because it
fits him let's put him to a side
can you please show me if not i would
like to move to deuteronomy 18 because
our
time's running up i don't have any
occasion in history
because this has not yet happened okay
thank you josh
three times already okay no problem so
what i'm going to do now i'm going to go
to do 2018 and i want to finish on this
point hopefully yeah
so let's can you open the